e gli altri ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono falli j e so che lo
aspettavate questo video
maledetti spero abbiate visto tutti il
video reaction fa i j chiama che era
quel video dove questo ragazzo
praticamente appreso della mia voce è
affatto dei preti telefonici con la mia
voce
visto il successo del video perché ha
fatto il successo incredibile ne ha
fatto un altro fa mi chiama 2 che adesso
andremo a fare andiamo facile reaction
insieme ci siete ragazze
lei sì contro sono fa vj e dj vj e dj va
bene è trimani nord da re di conoscerti
sono youtuber voglia dei un tubo ma ti
droghi breve vi devo finire qua basta
youtube ma ti droghi sono youtuber di
successo io non puoi fare queste cose
arona youtube esatto sono diventato
grosso come youtubers 3 milioni
d'iscritti preme tremila iscritti
no 3 milioni a 3 milioni danno un sacco
di soldi
[Applauso]
cosa vuoi dare una collaborazione a
eliat la mia prima con lavorazioni cogli
l'occasione uomo 100.000 like fire sia
fatto la figura di che diciamo a
cambiare tanto la gente non sia strada
ebit tra e poi invitate a nardò e vabbè
ma quindi sarà sicuramente un successo
anzi possiamo andare a [ __ ] adesso è
certo il palextra un corso perché star
lavoro questo che c'era lavoro non vai a
[ __ ]
forse la gente mi questo è il solito ma
ritorniamo al punto di prima con
galletti nel suo nome vediamo andate
verso fare per aiutarti cerca immagini
su fa vj su internet tac tac e contrasta
contattano che facciamo i video dei
fondali con denaro di pieghe del
tracciato no no no no dice sporzionare
deve andare a saperlo tutti gli anni
aveva dominato da negative a questo un
versamento di parlare prima scusate
questo capri punti anche iter sta
rivedendo testo guarda al limite vediamo
non era cosa che chi decide coattive ci
devono dare perché è una certa
reputazione lavanderia si chiama chi se
ne frega e dj e maria che deve vedere
gli permetteva che dice più grande e
quindi mi sono montato la testa e la
fama mi cambia ma se le civette facevano
l'amore con la figlia del dottore ma la
figlia del dottore proprio gioco la come
mika fa sapere che amerebbe a metà sul
sesso orale non di figura di cariati dà
del dottore fa come che si cura di
italiani
un'eccezione saluto antonio nessuno
vallini rete che fare allora il video
che fai
alla fine quando sarà lunga e invenzioni
e dc magari che ne so si dice che si sta
seguendo magari che ne so una nuova
collaborazione letti questa prova di
suspense
ok lo faccio subito zio io non so che dj
sia però mollerei un live di martin
garris pervenire attenzione quindi
ragazzi sto facendo questo video che
sono fa vj e dj che lo salutiamo che ci
segue grazie che ci segue
facciamo adesso facciamo i video insieme
andiamo a suonare a tomorrowland
bronczec apri ponte perché non vi conte
non va bene poi vediamo magari da una
università per apparizione va bene va
bene
il successo è assicurato si deve andare
e dando numero alterare magico ha fatto
questo video reparto vediamo alle
vittorie per ferentino saperne se lui
vede questo video che sto facendo adesso
reaction pensa che sia stato veramente
io a contattarlo secondo me alla fine
invece fuori che io devo farci veramente
la collaborazione con lui non ho mai
chiesto niente
senti ma l'hai visto hunger games che
hunger games hunger games dopo aver
finora dramma ma non lo dice il tuo
personaggio preferito quale
no mi hai visto twilight a ti dico la
verità mi dovrò per vararla testo
personaggio preferito di tu hai twilight
quale ben a un bravo della cia carella
bella kacar e dunque non l'iphone è
certo come fare non avere una fare molto
frate a facili simmons e dai 64 gb che
schifo i poveri ma sforna una cosa che
non deve mancare un grande complimento
il discorso soddisfacente zio ma guarda
ritirato il piuma al parte la moda c'è
male sia veramente messo a parlare di
telefonia c'era io non capisco come come
fai a prendere seriamente uno che al
telefono ti parla degli audio registrati
in quanto ne accorgi non è possibile ma
ascolta zia se io dicessi cercare un
video di fa vj fa vj tutto attaccato per
l'amor di dio ti ammazzo cosa
risponderesti far dj ma parità di
firenze ancona verona e chi lo sa
no no no no mio dio sto scherzando
perché lo spelling eretico eretto nel
corretto di origine fa vj fa vj canali j
con la j staccata è come scrivere chiara
chiaro a a staccata che cazzo mib
rappresenta a ecco un genio g eh lo so
finisce qua lo vito fa un sacco di
allora peccato ma questa roma stazione
dove si correrà sul web
io ho fatto un saluto a tutti quelli che
mi seguono quelli che mi seguiranno
e tutti i miei amici che hanno sempre
sostenuto e sono quelli che ti danno
alla porta giorno persone continuare a
realizzare torinista vorrei anche
salutare ma delle persone ma lavorava
per ammette anche a te è chiaro ci
auguriamo tanta qualità e così va bene
va bene va bene di garzelli raccomando
bella e ora esulta ma io vi giuro su dio
che non per allora io in genere quando
vedo un primo episodio di qualcosa poi
il secondo è sicuramente bello ma non è
mai bello come il primo secondo episodio
cazzo questa era più bello il secondo
del primo con me è più bello il secondo
episodio del primo è stata geniale mica
lui ci ha creduto dall'inizio alla fine
e stato stupendo lui saluto adige i big
blu che è fantastico dj sud che
salutiamo tutti che andrà ad ibiza e
farà un sacco di carriera che gli
auguriamo tutti quanti e quindi per
questa occasione ho comprato una console
da dj e andiamo a fare saltare le
persone ad ibiza ok io metto tutti i
pezzi di martin garics e tu dj pip mi
accompagni ci accompagnano a vicenda
jane smokers trovano due anni non sono
un cazzo di nessuno confrontano e merck
increment video che vi dovete solo
spostare dopo questo perché arriviamo
facciamo noi tutto facciamo i culi
quindi ragazzi spero che ho scritto vi
sia piaciuto erano di giuro non ho
parole
like lo merita secondo me è sta roba è
geniale ma veramente geniale cosa che ho
preso un argomento mi piace anche vari
social che quando io totale schizzi
alzate voci di schemi che ci vediamo al
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]